[موسيقى]
الناس اللي بتخاف من فكره التبرع كل حاجه
جديده على المجتمع عامه هيبقى فيها خوف في
الاول مع الوقت ولما يلاقوا ان الدنيا
تمام ماشيه تمام خلاص الخوف ده هيبتدي
يتراجع هي الفكره نفسها بالنسبه له جديده
عليه عمر ما حد طرحها قدامي فهي اي فكره
جديده بالنسبه للانسان عامه بيبقى خوف
لانه مش متعود عليها ومع الوقت خلاص
بتلاقي ما بيبقاش في خوف ده بينتهي يعني
الاعلام عليه دور كبير جدا لانه انا كنت
باسال الدكاتره اللي حواليا يعني انا
المفروض اسال مين ما هو الدكاتره اللي
حواليه بقى في سيستم بقى في قانون يقولوا
لي لا ما في قانون بيقول لا فسكت اذا كان
الدكاتره مش هتعرف انا المفروض
اساله اذا كان في بقى قانون يعني ينفع
اتبرع فديه همم
مسؤوليه من الاعلام في فنانين بيدعموا
الفكره زي الهام شاهين والصراحه عامله
موجود معنا كبير جدا ان هي بتطلع بس برده
مجهود فردي انا شايفه ان هو همم فنان واحد
اثنين اللي بيطلع يتكلموا عن الموضوع لازم
يبقى الاعلام له خطه للتوعيه عشان الناس
تقدر همم تشوف الفكره وتفهم اكثر عن
الموضوع ويبقى في اراء اطباء لان في ناس
عندها تخوف من حاجات معينه زي الموت يبقى
ازاي والحاجات دي دي انا ممكن اشرحها لك
بس اللي هيشرح احسن بيبقى دكتور مختص عشان
يشيل التخوف ده من جوه الناس